[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
22 فبراير يوم مميز في تاريخ المملكه
العربيه السعوديه فهو نافذه تاريخيه نطل
من خلالها لمعرفه نشوء هذا الكيان العظيم
فالسعوديه العظمى لها حكايه ممتده من
ثلاثه قرون بدات من العدم بسواعد الرجال
المخلصين فعام
1727 يحكي لنا القصه التي بدات من العاميه
البسيطه الى العالميه المتينه فقوامها
كالنخله المعطاه وسرعه تطورها كالفرس
العداء ليش لان همه سعودي مثل جبل طويق ان
كان همتنا مثل جبل طويق انت السحابه اللي
على طويق
ظله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فعند وصول الشمس الى نقطه الاعتدال
الخريفي ب 23 سبتمبر نحتفل باليوم الوطني
وهو اليوم الذي تحول فيه اسم مملكه الحجاز
ونجد وملحقاتها الى اسم المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وقبل وصول الشمس الى نقطه
الاعتدال الربيع ب 22 يوما نحتفل بيوم
التاسيس فاليوم الوطني فخر واعتزاز
ومعاصره ويوم التاسيس تاريخ واصول واصاله
بلاد الفناها على كل حاله وقد يؤلف الشيء
الذي ليس بالحسن ونستعذب الارض التي لا
هواء بها ولا ماءها عذب ولكنها
وطن
[موسيقى]